this is one of many dump sites for
electronic waste in Lagos Nigeria it
smells of burning plastic the waste
provides an income for many people but
the work is dangerous due to toxic smoke
and leaching heavy metals workers take
the e-waste apart by hand and resell the
raw materials the dump sites are illegal
this footage was shot secretly because
the waste pickers don't want to be
exposed they use one equipment to repair
the other they look what is good in work
and the rest they don't know what to do
with it so the idea one dumping them on
ground they are the warm bonding them
releasing dioxins and furans into the
atmosphere and the activities has
contaminated a lot of soil with levels
of heavy metals sometimes almost
happened at times the road directive
some electronic equipment comes from
developed countries as donations it's
supposedly usable but often it's just
trash second-hand electronic products is
the major ICT products being used in
developing countries because less than
20% of the population can afford to buy
new and modern electronic products but
this has been abusing that exporters of
second-hand products from developed
countries actually export more of
end-of-life equipment away if A&E
Ojinaga has come up with a different
solution for handling a waste he founded
a recycling company called eat era which
complies with government safety
regulations here we have the dismantling
area okay so each electronic parts that
is considered electronic waste or
e-waste is dismantled ok defragmented to
the original particular reason
the individual parts as you can see on
the table here and further down here we
have boards we have iron we have
speakers we have everything in its
individual parts
Bojan ogo invested in this machine the
only one of its kind in Nigeria it
allows the company to dismantle a waste
in a way that won't harm people or the
environment an exhaust hood contains the
toxic fumes we all know about the
e-waste crisis and the global e-waste
collide crisis especially in India China
you know Nigeria I felt that this is
something that that that hit my heart
and it's got to be dealt with right now
because there's no way you can run away
from the problem because it's the same
air you breathe is the same food you eat
as everybody else we are really in a
very deep very big very serious crisis
the global IT market relies on rapid
innovation
NIEM devices become obsolete very
quickly and end up as a waste
everything from televisions to computers
cell phones charges and more eat error
is Nigeria's first a waste recycling
company after dismantling the e-waste is
separated and shredded by raw material
much of it can then be sold
that's the company's main source of
income but that's not all no goes only
motivation I'm not the kind of person
that will see something wrong with
anyone or anything and not try to do
something no matter how small about it
I'd like being a pioneer I like doing
what other people are not doing and I
like affecting society positively and
setting the right example for Nigerians
around the world up 250 million tons of
electronic waste are expected to be
discarded in 2017 some of it will end up
on these waste dumps on the outskirts of
Legos but if AI neo Genaro has taken the
first step in turning this burden into a
sustainable resource